foreign
[Music]
we are back America welcome to another
epic year of the All-American tree
lighting here on Fox Square presented by
the five how about this tree huh it's
back and it's better than ever you're
going to want to stick around because
it's just a yeah go ahead and cheer
yeah get it out of your system
because very soon we're gonna have our
guests of honor hit that button to light
this sucker up and not in a bad way
if you remember last year I was bet he's
out here in the audience everybody say
hello this massive 50-foot tree you see
behind us was made right here in America
bored bred and then killed
they took a team of 50 people 4 000
hours to build this symbol of Christmas
and a crew of 20 people to assemble the
tree right here on Fox square and it is
pretty impressive the tree has 340
000 lights 12 000 ornaments that sit on
500 branches and it's topped with a six
foot tall star a tall star taller than
Greg Gutfeld that's not much a store
bigger than Gutfeld yes that's hard to
believe that is hard to believe
tonight we are joined by some familiar
faces to help us make some new memories
including some of your favorite Fox
hosts and their families Fox News
employees as well as members of the FDNY
and the NYPD and we'll honor them in
just a moment
[Applause]
we will also welcome members of New York
City's Police Athletic League the
largest independent Youth Development
not-for-profit organization in the city
Fox employees are helping make deserving
children's Christmas Dreams Come True by
donating over 400 gifts and they wrapped
every single present that you see right
here tonight
after a busy year in America it's nice
to let's just take a step back and
celebrate Traditions like this and
remember how important it is to come
together and focus on what truly matters
this tree is not just for us to enjoy we
want you watching at home to be able to
come here and make Christmas Memories
with your family and friends and of
course your pets too of course as you
can imagine
do we have a special surprise later Greg
are we going to meet someone that's near
and dear to your heart yeah very close
to me it's uh I don't want to is it now
are we doing it now the wedding yes are
we yeah we're gonna make them wait just
a little bit longer build up is killing
me I have one other thing I can do for
you though the lighting the All-American
Christmas tree would not be complete
without a blessing uh Timothy Cardinal
Timothy Dalton excuse me unfortunately
could not be here with us tonight but he
sent us this very special message here
good evening everybody Cardinal Timothy
Dolan here I wish I could be with you in
person but you'll understand it with my
family for turkey and pumpkin pie this
year in Washington Missouri so let us
pray
dear God we gather as a nation that
dares to say In God We Trust
We Gather as a country that claims to
say that we are one nation under God
never are those Noble sentiments more
evident than during this beautiful
Christmas season
And We Gather this evening to let you
know that Lord we need a little
Christmas we need a little Christmas yes
for us Christians who believe that
Christmas is the birth of Jesus the son
of God our savior but for all people of
all Faith or even none at all all those
beautiful Virtues Of Christmas Unity
friendship Joy hope peace coming
together as family and friends and
neighbors we need a little Christmas
right this very moment and thanks be to
God with this Christmas tree it's
beginning to look a lot like Christmas
and it's Christmas time in the city this
tree Evergreen reminds us that life is
meant to be Eternal this tree rooted
rooted in the soil reminds us that our
lives are be to be rooted in you dear
Lord and in all the virtue and all the
nobility to which you call us things
those virtues and that nobility that are
so beautifully represented by well like
the Police Athletic leave and like
league in the New York police department
and the fire department of New York
please might this Christmas season
indeed bring us peace and unity
reconciliation hope light and life for
you are God forever and ever amen
thank you Cardinal Dolan Reverend
Jacques DeGraff is up by the tree to
share his Christmas blessing
America America God shed its Grace on
thee and shine thy good with Brotherhood
from sea to shining sea let us pray
our father and our God the god of
Abraham Isaac and Jacob Esther and Mary
we come before your throne of grace as
humbly as we know how just to say thank
you thank you that we live in an America
that is blessed with many freedoms but
even at this time we have those who are
hungry and those who are homeless at
Christmas time and we ask that you would
remember them in a special way blessed
to our First Responders who run into
danger to protect the rest of us and
those who would stand on the wall to
protect our many freedoms we ask that
you would bless this city and this
nation in a very special way at this
time of year these blessings we ask in
the precious name of arisen Savior and
the men who love God said
and the women who love God said
and the men and women who love God said
all right thank you Reverend Rabbi
Joseph potasnik is here as well to say a
few words about the importance of the
holiday season
thank you judge I receive the most
unusual invitation from Fox someone
called and said Rabbi you believe in
free speech I said of course I do he
said well good come give one tonight
years ago there was a magazine called
life
afterlife there was a magazine called
people
after people it was a magazine called us
after us there was a magazine called
self
we started with life we went to self we
Jews read from right to left therefore
it may begin with self
But ultimately it's about all of us
as one people
who have to make this life meaningful
for all people there is a beautiful
blessing that says may the branches be
as strong as the roots
we are many branches here today
different backgrounds and beliefs but we
also have common roots
so for some it's Christmas father says
Hanukkah together we all believe in
Thanksgiving may we continue to be
thankful
and give light and love to one another
amen amen
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else